we're joined from Westminster by the
security minister Brandon Lewis thank
you for being with us and miss Lewis
good morning well we just heard from
John Claude gingka I know that you've
been listening in to the interview he
was saying that if there is a No Deal
brexit there will be a border between
Northern Ireland and the Republic is
that your understanding well I couldn't
hear the details in - I couldn't really
hear what he was saying but your team
helpfully gave me a bit of an outline
look what I would say is we're all
working very hard and there are lots of
reasons why we want to make sure we get
a deal as the Prime Minister has
outlined and as he'll be going out to
the EU to do in mid-october at that EU
council obviously getting to deal is our
key priority there's a huge amount of
work going on in government as well as
you know to be ready for no deals should
it happen because the promise has been
clear and I think people when I've gone
around the country very clear they want
to see this done they want us to leave
you you and get on and deliver on what
they voted for in 2016 and we have to be
ready to do that I know that you are say
that you're trying to get a deal but we
need to be honest now don't we about
what the consequences that No Deal might
be there will be a hard border went
there between Northern Ireland and the
Republic in the event of a no deal
brexit well we're doing a huge amount of
work to prepare for what No Deal will
mean that is absolutely the right thing
for us as a government to do to be
prepared for whatever outcome may there
may be obviously as I said as you
acknowledge we want to get a deal and as
I believe young Luke has said himself
that there is a very good possibility of
getting the deal he was very positive
about that from what I read in the
reports and of the interview you've just
had but we are not going to be
publishing an update to the yellowhammer
work that obviously has been a huge
amount of work done since that second of
August paper was released there's been a
daily meeting of the committee of
ministers that looks at preparation for
no deal on a huge amount has been done
since then there's a lot of different
things we can do to make sure that the
country is ready we're working a whole
range of those things as I said we'll
publish an update soon and I myself from
going over to Ireland literally as soon
as I finish speaking to you this morning
our Security Minister you are across the
detail if we leave without a deal
there's a security risk in Northern
Ireland and the Republic of
increase well we're very fortunate to
have a fantastic set of people who work
to keep us safe through our police and
our agencies who keep us safe both right
across the United Kingdom and work with
their partners both of a public of
Ireland and partners around the EU now
obviously there is a range of law
enforcement tools that our police use
with our partners in the EU we would
want to have a really really ambitious
security agreement with the EU when we
leave you that's one of the things we
are negotiating of course even if you
aren't part of EU you can still be part
of things like Europe or the United
States it's evolved quite heavily with
you at post there's still a huge amount
of options therefore so I'm confident
that our security and our safety will be
protected by those brilliant teams that
we work with every day and who I'll be
visiting later on this afternoon you see
it is quite frustrating with under six
weeks to go to not be able to get really
straight answers to questions that
people are really worried about like
would there be a border if there isn't
it deal would security the security risk
increase if there isn't a deal I mean
the fact is you can't guarantee can you
that the security risks won't change the
people in the UK well as you we are
reviewing our security status as a
country all the time that's something
that's ongoing day by day depending on
what's happening both in the UK and
around the world
regardless and aside from brexit itself
that's something we keep under constant
review but we are always looking at how
we make our country safer regardless of
whether we have a deal or no deal with
the EU there are opportunities for us as
a country both in terms of how we work
across with Interpol and countries like
the fires around the world and do more
with them as well as still as the US as
I say to do playing a important part
with you a poll but I am confident as I
outlined a week or two ago that our
security is in a good state but it is
therefore again a key reason why we want
to make sure we have a good deal with
you so we can play an important part in
helping the EU with their security as
much as working on our security but I'm
confident we will be secure regardless
of where we end up with brexit but our
focus is on getting a deal I mean just
looking at for example the operation
yellowhammer document I know you say
that this is being updated but this is
still our basis of what the government's
no deal planning assumptions are the
worst case reasonable worst case
scenario
it says that if there isn't a deal law
enforcement data and information sharing
between the UK and the EU will be
disrupted and it's time to be honest
isn't it there is a security risk if we
leave without a deal well it needs to be
very clear about a couple of things
you've what you just outlined look
you're quite right that is a yellow
hammer document from the second of
August a lot has moved on since then as
I say that ministerial meeting has been
meeting daily putting a whole range of
work but we're national security and a
whole range of measures that we're
looking at to be ready for no deals
should we have to be in that situation
we obviously want to be focused on
delivering a deal but we also need to be
clear about what those law enforcement
measures are I mean one of the key
things around there are things like the
European Arrest one that's about what we
do if we want to bring somebody who's
committed an offense here in the UK back
into the UK there were methods pre the
European Arrest Warrant obviously it's a
faster simpler process but our actual
day-to-day security as I said I'm
confident we've got agencies that law
enforcement work with our partners
around the world and our partners in
Europe is something the week and he's
sure that we continue to be safe and
secure obviously we want to get a deal
we want to be able to make sure that we
take advantage of working together with
our partners in Europe for the benefit
of everybody okay now we are awaiting
the verdict from the Supreme Court on
whether or not the Prime Minister acted
illegally in Prague in Parliament if
they rule that that was against the law
will Parliament return earlier than
planned well we've always been very
clear the Prime Minister's been clear
that we respect the law we respect the
rule of law obviously we have to all
wait and see what the ruling of the
Supreme Court is next week before we can
come to a final conclusion about what
the implications of that out I spoke to
David Cameron a couple of days ago we're
gonna hear it interview later in the
program but he told me that the one
piece of ice he would give to Boris
Johnson would be to don't break the law
is that good advice all of us as
ministers at all times are very
determined to make sure that we abide by
the rule of law the Prime Minister the
number-10 have been very clear about
Biden by the rule of law but we also
should be very open about the fact that
we needed to pro Parliament to have a
Queen's Speech it is right that we set
out a really clear ambitious and
exciting domestic agenda investing in
our NHS in our security and police
forces as well as our education all of
the things the Prime Minister Boris
Johnson said he wanted to do
on the steps of down history wants to
get on with that we need a queen speech
to do that now I want to ask you about a
couple of other stories and lots of a
viewers will be very concerned to read
the reports about what is happening with
Thomas Kirk the travel company
reportedly on the verge of collapse will
the government step in given the fact
that so many people look to be stranded
abroad if this happens well I'm sure
you'll appreciate and I hope your
viewers appreciate would be
inappropriate for me to comment on the
individual financial situation of a
particular company I understand from
what I've read this morning myself as
many of your viewers will have done
there are discussions and conversations
going on through the day and obviously I
hope that they come to a positive
conclusion I mean the reports that we're
reading say 165,000 British
holidaymakers could be need to could be
needed to be flown home can you
guarantee that if this happens and of
course as you say it's important not to
speculate too much on what is going on
but if that happens can you guarantee
that all of those holidaymakers will be
returned well as I've seen reports
earlier today and many much some people
may recall we had a situation some time
ago a year or two ago where we had to
repatriate people back into the UK and
the government work to do that but I
again would just say it would be
inappropriate for me as a government
minister to comment on the individual
financial situation of a private company
so I'm going to hold back from doing
that this morning okay and now we're
here at labor conference a little later
on today and that people at this
conference they're going to be debating
and voting on a motion to abolish
private schools is that something that
you think it's a good idea to improve
social mobility I find it slightly
surprising the to see this from the
Labour comments bear in mind a number of
frontline labour parliamentarians
themselves have used private schools
their children including some of their
Shadow Cabinet I believe we have a
really good mix of Education in this
country I haven't had an interest in
that in the past myself I think it's
good that everybody gets a chance
whatever type of school is right for
them in the hotel to have that freedom
to choose what is right for them and for
their child I think that's a matter of
personal choice and we should be very
proud of the educational system we've
got across the public and private sector
here in the United Kingdom what about
the idea that they were putting forward
to scrap off that the schools inspectors
I find that absolute
standing I'm not quite sure what what
logic maybe is for getting rid of a
mechanism that makes sure that public
schools all schools are actually
performing to a level that is good and
appropriate for their children and means
that parents have got the information
they need to make the decisions that are
right for them their family and their
children I think it's astounding I would
imagine that anybody watching this and
reading about this would just be shocked
the labor prepared to play such games
with children's education okay Brandon
Lewis thank you very much for being on
the program we'll get some at the labor
reaction some of those education
policies shortly where we're here as I
said at Labor Party conference we're now
joined by the shadow health secretary
John Ashworth thank you very much for
being with us a bright and early this
morning good morning now you've got a
new policy out haven't you what is it
that you want to do well I've been
looking at the way in which
prescriptions